welcome to this week's winners on
Wednesday Russell Leeds here I am joined
by the amazing
oh my absolute pleasure to have you guys
here thank you very much you've got just
been traveling a track you've got a very
very interesting story which I've had
the pleasure of sort of seeing them
further over the last 12 months or so so
what are we starting to be getting for
before we met before you met Samuel came
on the crash course tells little about
what your life was was like yeah so
basically I worked for Lloyds Bank for
about good ten years the sauce bits in
our office I started off in chairs and
then from there I went into commercial
banking yeah yeah so that was
interesting because for about three
years I was dealing with actual property
investors I was dealing with their bank
accounts so I kind of had a gist of the
property side of it but just from
listening and to other people so work
working Lloyd's income we kind of a bit
jealous oh yeah definitely because we
worked in SME so it was anything up to
25 mil turn over a year so these people
had a lot of properties the under
developers they were you know they had
five or six hundred property portfolios
so they were really big investors so I
was obviously jealous because in the
sense that they're doing so well and
I've got no idea how to get him there
didn't have the money to do what they
were doing
yeah so just kind of sat back and
watched and thought I was amazed about
what these people are doing but in some
ways I mean say to me before that in
some ways looking at how actually how
big it was almost it felt unachievable
to you at this stage investing in
property felt was something that had to
be massive that you had to have lots of
money to get started is that correct
hundred percent yeah from what from my
point of view yeah because I was looking
at these kind of people start thinking
you know they've got millions of pounds
and you know I'm never gonna get but
even it's just to buy one house you know
a decent house tour in how you need a
lot of money mmm which at the time you
know I should list a little spending so
everything like came in and went out
yeah I'd never had the money to invest
in property that's why I never thought
I'd ever bill to get into it yeah you
had a pretty good job yeah you're not
you married you've got a pretty nice
line yeah so what was it in you that
made you think I want to get into
property well you know what
what equals Oh had he I mean I enjoyed
what I did definitely if he was
interesting every day was different but
I just knew wasn't long-term I couldn't
be for the rest of my life I didn't want
to retire still working behind it you
know a desk so I knew I wanted to do
something but I was out there finding
stuff so I was over than YouTube trying
to find out different things to do be
Amazon eBay or whatever it was but I
just didn't appeal to me so I just sat
back and just you know went with it just
one day where I had a recommendation
he said Samuel leaves property investor
I was like a 57 minute video and its
really only really that watch till the
beginning to the end that was that long
and for me it was that one video that
chain my whole perspective on property
but really you know what I've been
taught through voiceover was working for
all the time yes so you kind of keen to
get out of the job
yeah he's mentioned Amazon's you set up
an Amazon okay I said okay
that was about it but you know you watch
some videos and say yeah it was really
good Amazon's really good FB is amazing
do it do it do it you can make 50 60 70
thousand pounds a month I thought great
and then you watch another video and
said well it's not as easy as I said you
know there's always one video that would
say yes or more Vidya that would said no
so I just didn't click the risk yeah so
I had always just different things I'm
alone just a net wuzzy here's an example
that was you were looking for different
I mean obviously came across property
you Samuli looking for different ways to
get rid of the hours why do you think
the you couldn't see his object because
in many ways you had a great life wasn't
like you were struggling yeah why why
did you feel that that wasn't for you
what was wrong with that I just wanted
the independence that you know I could
do what I wanted to do like a lot of the
times when you're working in an office
space so it's really busy as well you're
kind of restricted so you have to like
say for example I was talking to place
before about holidays you let's say you
wanted to go away or you needed a day
off let's say to go somewhere it was
really hard because the business the
office was so busy it hard to get time
off that the restriction I didn't like
you know for example the pay as well the
pay was okay was good you knows it was
achievable you could do what you wanted
to do but for you to go progress
anywhere you had to
really push and everyone else is pushing
at the same time and it was just like a
loophole like where I was just like a
rat race if you want to call it
well yes I wasn't getting anywhere and I
didn't feel feeling motivation to go any
further in what I was doing so the early
particular moments that stick out in
your head about things that you you kind
of mentioned that you felt like sort of
trapped in the office job anything that
happened that you that you missed out on
the Maggie thing right that's it now was
there any defining moment where you
thought enough is enough
yeah again max having the really petty
pick it came down to having time off
like I was there five days a week and it
was just one day like the way they said
to me was you know this is business news
obviously businesses always come first I
know that but you know the holidays are
not there you can't just take time off
whenever you want to I was getting
talked to as if I was like nothing you
know I mean like was law in the company
and you know you don't really mad that
much and basically it was just that one
moment this one episode it happened that
you get busy that no saying that what we
were saying is how his how it stays you
have not said so I felt like I was just
trapped there like in you know in prison
like I do I do go there 9:00 to 5:00
absolutely you know go crazy and no time
to do anything else it was very very
busy is really stress for the
environment in that sense but rewarding
so from there and what I thought you
know what I mean I need to need to get
out of money to get out of this yeah
yeah so you kind of crosstime with video
on YouTube yeah further video you
watched it all the way through
yeah what action did you take after
after that will have what would be their
sign up for the crash book and from
there I heard device book so I was on
straightaway that same night ordered is
by law no yeah by yeah bought the book
and again this I'm don't read books the
last time I read the book was I was in
school and that was through false so and
this is amazed and sold my wife at the
time that I read this book like in the
same nightmare she got it
I really from the beginning to the end
and I was amazed all the way through
some time my god I've been told it's
time you need money you need money to
invest in property and this guy's saying
no you don't all you need a very little
money to invest you know be through
venture N or rent to us a
all these options even so I'm gonna be
this guy you know I know he's doing
something right here definitely so in
the book you mentioned about his free to
their crash course so falling in love I
think in about three weeks time there
was one in Manchester which is close to
me yeah so booked under went on that
crash course and by the end of the two
days I was sold
although you know I can do this
definitely yeah I knew I needed the push
car safety before that I'm that kind of
person to procrastinate a lot I was a
very lazy person so I'd say I'd do
something like the biggest spark and
then next day be like you know so I
needed I knew I needed extra push also
on the crash course I was very happy
with it I could have continued with that
for wanted to but I knew I wanted to go
a bit further I wanted to go into
service accommodation eventually I
wanted are going to buy refurbish
refinance
in the end so I knew I needed the
advanced training yeah so sign up for
the advance training did that and then
from there onwards join me I joined the
Academy actually the same time on the
crash course Missy I did everything in
the crash yeah I thought I need to do
this I need the support I need someone
to mentor me and he still want to push
me and I make this investment I'm gonna
give the knowledge today for the rest of
my life by the same time I know I have
to do it yeah I've made that big
commitment so I have to do in tomorrow
yeah we've kind of pointed out something
that everyone does but the fact that you
record which is procrastinate yeah a lot
of people do that they're very excited
about something and then and then that
wanes you know and then they get
interested when it starts getting tough
or getting hard true but the fact that
you kind of realize that and then you
took the appropriate action to make sure
that didn't happen
because I feel the economy is great for
the training but a lot of it is the
mindset in the environment as well
hundred the people that you're around
people that push you bring you up the
coach that you have the phone calls
we're so did you find that particularly
helpful definitely as much as that the
training side of it was important that
side was more important to me seeing
other people do it or you know just
putting a post out there on Facebook or
whatsapp forever and then for them to
come back instantly and say this is all
you need to do get the answers give them
motivation actually seeing other people
do it
my situation yeah and that was a push
that I needed and for if someone just to
say you can do it and everyone says that
I'm the Academy are in the groups
wherever they are the everyone just was
so good and you know even though no one
knew me it felt like we were family and
everyone was looked after each other so
that really did definitely help me
awesome so you came along to the crash
course when and then you might join the
Academy yeah when did you join the
Academy so I wasn't able to join the
Academy until it was September we had my
one-to-one September 2018 yeah okay
brilliant so what happens for you to get
your first deal how long did that take
so I basically from the crash course I
want you to take action so I want you to
basically buy my first property yeah HM
oh so I started that from the crash
course yep but from there onwards up
until when I had my one time with Samuel
I was having really of struggling a lot
to get a mortgage just because I was
getting the wrong type of mortgage I
only found that hour and tell and then
literally bang he changed mortgage
broker and yeah mortgage came straight
in so it'll yeah I mean my one to one
was great was amazing but but one little
moment where someone was like what's the
problem I told him what it was it was
for this mortgage broker and that was it
yes fully within three weeks from there
but the house was complete it was mine
yeah that's fantastic
so so that is a full bed Mila
yeah and where's that doesn't crew I
think Rick oh yeah it's not too far
working where I know it's quite a fire
out yeah that's quite far in that sense
but I just other time I spoke to some of
the crash course and they were saying
all the time that you know there was a
good area to university I think really
the good area here just to kind of stuff
so I thought okay that's fine and I just
went with it and how long did that take
to rent out that it took a bit out at
the beginning because because that was
one of the mistakes that I made the
beginning which I didn't am I making was
a it was quite about an hour
just over an hour drive for me to get
there so because I was working at the
time I was something to do it like every
weekend so it took me a long time to get
it up and running together the standard
like give a fire alarms and all that
kind of stuff
but once it was on the market I
literally I I did
fully occupied within about four weeks
that's pretty good yeah really good
yeah and that making you decent returns
now yeah yeah hey yeah did you buy that
with your own money that was yes so
basically the good thing with the thing
that list was ever had no family and
friends I have money so basically I was
able to get the deposit for that and
basically buy that with kindness my own
money now because we paid them back yeah
from that but yeah basically that's lost
my house nice and light was female
borrowed the money you've got started
strapped borrow the money and then
you've used the money that you're making
from it yeah them back yeah yeah so
that's what we call an infinite return
on investment yeah yeah that's pretty
good yeah that's what I do with
everything I'm really looking at since
that I've got family and friends though
that's one thing that I heard a lot in
their crash course or in the in the
academies that tell everyone what you do
yeah and I hear doing that I'm that kind
of person I like to hide everything so I
was like yeah what do you do I've left
the bank and they're like what do you do
another no invest in property or do you
and then when they heard that I do what
hate you more
I had a few essays at the time then as
well and all like oh we've got some
money Jona invest and I was like
brilliant and I was literally talking to
random people of what do you do and the
funny story was I was at a shop once and
I'm good talking to the sky there and
all this and he goes all what do you do
I told him that invest in property I've
got some service accommodationist really
cause do you do Airbnb in that kind of
stuff oh yeah we use that platform
because I used to be super hosts for
Airbnb and I did a lot of apartments and
as I'm looking for something to get into
I want a partner and he had literally
he's got thousands got literally lost
money lying around waiting to invest in
service accommodation so that's one
giant venture that's gonna happen just
from me telling him what to do and
happens everywhere yeah yeah
soon as the pirate shows the power of
announcing what unit Dave and everything
as well yeah getting people around you
having a vision yeah just so getting
engaged always straight and so you start
the crash course you then sighs during
the Academy you start the probe that's
going for HM oh yeah you sat down with
something they helped you get your HMO
sorted that was your first deal at what
point did you leave your job at the bank
so I left the bank
it was literally I think it was around
October so about a month
yeah yeah okay and at that times you
only have the one Dale at that time I
had the one one deal that was making me
money which was the HMO but I also just
secured my first service accommodation
vernian a in Birmingham yeah and it was
a really good location I got it was a
really good deal I got as well this is
just from doing viewings like in one day
and now like ten viewings I've got one
that said yes and it was a really good
location and because I knew that wasn't
really good money you know at the time
it wasn't I took that kind of leap of
faith I thought you know what I'm
working five days a week in the bank and
I haven't got time I was getting phone
calls from a state agency in the day
yeah but we've got a strict policies
that because we got sensitive
information around his iPhones are too
locked away so I was missing out on
these deals I was missing out on like
you know estate agents list is ringing
me I thought I can't do this yeah I
tried as much as I could I got to the
point that I can't do this I'm missing
out so I took the leap of faith and I
just sign right to leave my job that's
quite big cool isn't it it was massive
for me yeah a lot of people will ask
that question it's a very big question
to ask I've just wanna say about on the
podcast we yeah of you heard yeah
at what point do you make that call so I
suppose you made it you had some money
coming in and I need you make from your
HMO profit averages around 700 a months
okay so you've got a bit of money coming
in so you know that the system works
yeah at that point you know okay I can
commit to leaving my job now because I
know they've got time yeah I can
continue to do this not will make money
but I will become financially right yeah
which you now are yeah trivia come back
to later thank you very much yeah and so
how much money how many deals do you
have right now at the moment that making
money I have five I'll do five deals and
you know making how much money an
average about four thousand a month not
four thousand a month year which is
fantastic yeah well how much money were
you making in the bank you don't want
Mexican yes okay yearly salary there was
twenty one thousand twenty one thousand
yeah yeah
that's not very much no that's the thing
you see people who just think are you
work at the bank and he
you know this is things trigger er you
must making a lot of money these two
always think that had a lot of money
yeah it wasn't a kiss you know today I
was on 21 thousand a year so see making
far more money now than you were
anywhere that yeah basically what my
income was replaced from I'd say about
one-and-a-half service accommodation so
just from the service accommodation side
I make more money from that then I did
when I was working in the office and
then and they were managed as well not
managing myself I'm using a manager to
manage those service accommodations and
they still making me more money than I
was when I was working in the bank
receive more than double your income
yeah and you may only work in far less
hours than you want yeah definitely yeah
well before I said credible so what are
the plans what the plans were the future
now before which maybe four and a half
grand a month
that sort of ticking over yeah well so
imagine you you you you're keen to get
your teeth into city projects yeah
definitely I mean I've got one another
service accommodation project coming a
bus so busy too as to apartments so I
want to kind of complete that first and
then from there my kind of final stage
or it's not final stage but my end role
was basically to buy houses men get them
refurbished to refinance them and then
to rent them so the brrrr if you want to
call it yeah and that ultimate goal so
pleased to have the cash flow to be to
be able to go and do that so obviously
want to just go out and that way I'm
kind of in the morning the assets myself
yeah which is what I really want you to
do I knew you know for long term that
was a poor know the answer yone on yes
and the same time make a passive income
from each month yeah so that's the next
step now so luckily for me I've got a
really good friend of mine died my best
friend and he's a builder so he's agreed
that a lot of the projects that I'm
gonna do he's gonna help me with them
yeah which is gonna help me a lot
so that Sarah also just kind of rinse
and repeat so do want make money from
that put your money and pulling money
out do it again just keep doing it and
hopefully get bigger so keep getting
bigger projects bigger bills you know a
big I don't know hotels that kind of
stuff in the end yeah I want to go
bigger in the future but for the time
being it's gonna be buying the house you
know what other things I've kind of
noticed from your stories you seem to be
good at getting good
around you yeah lend you money you know
that we were the building people who
have with that how have you managed to
do that is there any tips you people are
watching that maybe feel a bit isolated
maybe a family that maybe don't support
them so a lot of people are normally
that when they want to when I want to
get into property or anything that they
you know try and hold them back or would
say that no don't be stupid stay in your
job yeah what would you say was a tip to
get people you know around you and
supporting you and helping you for me
personally what I did was I mean thank
before that I was kind of trustworthy in
the sense that people trusted me the
knew I was you know the new was a nice
guy and on the knew I was a nice guy
again it was just telling them while I
was doing explaining to them I think if
you go straight and say look I'm gonna
buy a house I wanna rent it out have you
got any money that would never work for
me that the key was not asking them
directly for money number one and number
two it was basically explained to them
what the project was so for example out
set a person yeah what do you do I'm a
property investor have got these service
accommodations coming up it's cost me
this much money so only cost me four
thousand we're going to set up and now
it's making me eczema how many each
month and when they'd hear that story
that what I did personally when the see
is for yourself that you're doing this
you know works that automatically say or
hang on me now I've got some money to
decide you wanna use my money and I was
like that's how it works for me yeah so
people actually willing to give the
money wants to hear your story or your
kind of projects are working yeah and
this is how much money it's working is
you have to be honest to them now tell
them look it's not all you know it's not
a fantasy land where everything just
works and the money comes in from day
one they are struggles at the beginning
the Alps and downs of it but eventually
when he put the work in you get the
money out so for me it was just like
seeing being honest
telling them what you do explaining it
and if they've got the money they'll
bill definitely say to you look here
I've got some money you know I don't
really go the joint venture or drooly
invest it for me and then just give me
extra turn I'll be like that's fine with
me yeah yeah you also mentioned that
you're a nice guy
yeah so you would say maybe you support
other people in there and then
as a real if you go around supporting
people encouraging people to build
people up maybe they're gonna wonder the
same yeah i'm 3% yeah so before property
anyway like this is putting my mom mrs.
eller this is my downfall but i used to
always put other people in front of me
so i'd always want to like have them i
get pleasure in helping them whatever it
was being small or big problems whatever
it was and always want to help someone
else out and i think that just kind of
came around so people obviously when
they heard that I was doing properties
and they're still finding out they want
to help like well they're gonna know now
yeah it's really yeah so yeah it's just
there have been nice obviously house but
I think being honest is more important
to be realistic by saying that oh yeah
I've got you know what house and it's
making me five thousand pound a month I
one house is it's not realistic to be
realistic really figures and you explain
to them what you're doing
the Millea trust you yeah they trust you
but I think it's like is that you got a
piece off into their shoes if you had
let's say five thousand ten thousand
pounds you know are you gonna want to
give that your money to them did you
trust them in a fret mmm but then when
they see you're actually doing it
yourself it's much easy for them to say
he got he's five thousand pound he's ten
thousand whatever it is
yeah and we're happy to invest with you
or understand BIA on our behalf
brilliant what would you say was the
biggest struggle that you've had in the
journey because you're obviously up be
you know kind of guard which is great
but what would you say was the biggest
struggle you got to overcome the biggest
struggle for me personally was I mean I
really thought it would be the the side
of me that basically doubts myself and
you know think he's not gonna work you
know the mental side of it yeah which it
did happen a little bit at the beginning
but that only have the biggest struggle
for me was actually a lot of the
properties that I obtained in the
beginning I'd say I went into them kind
of just like thinking you know I'll just
I'll just do it and whatever happens
happens you know like that you know
after the training that's when I realize
actually you know what you need to do
your research do your sit down to this
do that so the first two properties that
I got there was problems with them like
at the beginning with the service
accommodation you know I didn't know
about negotiating for
trying to get no deposits you know going
through the deposit replacement
insurance trying to get one month free
rent so you can do the property up I
didn't know anything like that or if I
did either
basically didn't hero so I kind of like
threw myself in the beginning where I
was paying all of the written out of my
own pocket at the beginning yeah that
was the biggest struggle but once I've
learned that I hung in a minute you know
one little cost I had on essays or
service accommodation with the selves
I realized hang on a minute this is
other place other ways he can save money
so for me it was at the beginning
strongly it took me time to get this
first two project set up yeah and it was
just costing me money and I really did
you start that before you went on the
service combination training yeah did
yeah
yeah okay so I wasn't aware of it basic
I love tips and tricks that you teach
and then you went on the training and
yeah training I was like yeah yeah I was
glad I did obviously I mean I was making
lots of noise okay so then the next two
service accommodations I got after that
there were no deposits in the ask if
like you know a thousand pound 1200
pound deposits and they introduced him
to the Insurance Scheme and they were
like okay that's fine we'll do that so
it was just saving me money in the
beginning and I was I was more prepared
to like as soon as I get the keys that's
it I need to go in this trip way to
furnish it I need to get the
photographer industry aware and take it
on the booking platform straightaway
yeah all this time
which is what I was doing before yeah
yeah and then you and then if you
wasting time in the early stages you'd
have paying the rent on every time
exactly yeah okay one of the problems of
being a positive person I suppose
there's not many because it's by far but
sometimes that you do go into something
you just assume which is a good actually
to have it waiting like you say is
important do your due diligence on you
and you do learn you make sure you're
doing it the correct way
hundred percent so that's one of my
sometimes problems as III seriously fine
yeah yeah it's my biggest problem yeah
so what would you say it was the biggest
tip then biggest tip that you could give
20 on watching there's a mess what's in
your shoes
as you know got a a decent job but they
want to get out of it and they don't
know they don't know how to do that or
what to do what to do any any big tips
for them or Yvonne yeah I mean I give
this advice on a daily basis you know
still from what colleagues who managed
to work with I actually got one
colleague to come on to the crash course
and she's doing really well but my tip
would just be that you know anyone can
do it if I can do it I mean I never ever
thought I'd be able to do in a million
years so I thought I would I never
thought myself as a property investor
ever so if I can do it anyone can do it
so the first step would be based on my
experiences definitely just get online
first and have a few you know hours or
whatever you want to do look it's
because that's what changed it for me
you know get the book read it get some
understanding but most importantly just
getting the crash course you do believe
that you can do yeah I mean it's free
what you got to realize just two days
you know it's a free if free to their
cause and that'll be enough for you to
realize hang on a minute
I can do this and that's the biggest
thing is the knowledge that you can do
it the the confidence which she gives
you so I would say to them just get out
there get on the crash course is free
and then just take it from there yeah
just believe you can do it and just get
out there and start yes I imagine that
you have to you can't be negative about
otherwise it's not gonna work if you
always believe you stuff like that
always that's what you've learned
recently no I never believed in myself
and I know I know it's just something
that I've basically now that has
happened and it's worked and the kind of
environment of people have been around
you know positive people like yourself
like some young people in the Academy
the group's just seeing them being so
positive just stepping back and watching
them is basically build up my confidence
in the property side area the it's just
the knowledge yeah
so that belief that you have gotten
yourself how are you gonna use that in
the next year or so what can we expect
to see from ya in the next year so
definitely be able to see B buy more
properties definitely so doing a lot
more projects
refurbish refinance projects I mean just
kind of getting out of our bubble as
well because at the moment I'm very
quiet like on social media or that kind
of stuff and I don't like to know a gal
then say this is all I'm doing to
everyone
because this is how I am so the two
things I is that you'll definitely be
able to see more projects innocence of
buying and refurbishing houses and just
getting myself just a bit more out there
so more people can approach me and say
you know what we've got some money
you're doing it you know Joe and invest
it for us it'll be like yeah that's fine
and what should go what you hope in to
achieve Effie is the goal is I mean my
I've might be optimistic but my goal was
yeah yeah yeah is that basically I want
to Rob's retire young so I want you to
build a portfolio properties where it's
making enough passive income for me I've
got properties there and if you know my
children could benefit from it
so be in the next 10 years 20 years I
want to basically just kind of reduce
what I'm doing and it's been more time
with family and just enjoyed the money
really yeah but having that kind of say
for that in the future of what these
properties are in my name yeah you know
I can help out my family if I need to
which I'm already doing now at the
moment so the other future is just
building the portfolio amazing fantastic
well it's been an absolute pleasure to
have you on on the show that you know
the people out there that may be stuck
in it you haven't gone from a terrible
position
you know you had a decent job you were
getting by you have sometimes we get
people on here we were pressed or yeah
and then they need that so you haven't
had that now just a normal person from
their normal area having a normal job
you know just thought you know what I'm
not gonna settle for normal yeah and I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this I'm gonna come
fight you spray and you've already do in
just a few months double during comes
you then absolutely amazing well
hopefully it'll be a big inspiration
people that watch thank you very much
you said it yeah thank you very much
thank you so much for watching the video
that is the reason why I'm doing this
your success is my oxygen every single
week we've got people becoming
financially free if you'd like to see
more success to units you can do that
right here
but what I'd really suggest is why don't
you come and join us at the property
investors crash course come on on my
guest completely free and I'll
personally be there for two days to help
you get started you can see what happens
right here what you'll notice is all of
these stories they all start at the
crash course so come along my guests
can't wait to see you there peace